is known as the queen of rock and roll
and for more than three decades
she carried out sold out uh world tours
all around the globe she sold more than
180 million albums with hits including
What's Love Got to Do With It Private
Dancer and the best now she became most
famous in the late 1960s she was singer
of the band I can Tina Turner review but
that real worldwide success came as a
solo artist and you can tell what an
icon she was she was the subject of a
blockbuster film called What's Love Got
to Do With It that was out in the early
1990s it told her life story including
the turbulent times in her love life but
also actually right now you can go and
see the Tina Turner musical in the West
End that opened in 20 18 and Tina Turner
herself was part of the team that
brought that show to the west end it's
on tonight in the center of London and
people can still book tickets for that
until February of next year so no doubt
there will be a rush on any remaining
tickets for that but a real loss Tina
Turner dying after a long illness we're
told she was 83 although she'd been born
in nut Bush Tennessee born Anna May
Bullock in November of 1939. it was at
her home in kuznacht near Zurich in
Switzerland that she died with that news
emerging today
from her team who said that she was a
successful worldwide as a solo artist
and that the world loses a music legend
and a role model